[音楽]
まず皆さん
dea
[音楽]
はじめのスマホやないかい
10号っと
ああああああ
[音楽]
プーペ
おおおおおお
[音楽]
ブーンブーンは ran いっ
それは富士
masaki
やっぱり融合だよなぁ
源さん
えっ
masaki
ここだよここ気づいてくれよどこにいるんだよ
隠れてないで出てこいよ源さんのスマホの中だよえっ
ああああああああ
[音楽]
本当にスマホの中なのかそうなんですよ
昨日始め産地で転んで気づいたらスマホの中に減ってて出れないと
ん
まあ彼がそのことが対してしまった原因は
15分なことであると思われ
赤城山お腹すい母たちはご飯を食べる必要がなくなってしまう彼はスマホを増税する
ことが
ごはんになってしまったん
[音楽]
お風呂は1年1階台所で俺が彼は笑ったけど思う
な先がそのほど合体してからかなりの日にちが経つのね
俺たちはこの生活になり始めたいと一緒に公園に行くこともあれば
一緒にメロンソーダーどういうこともあった
マサキはスマホながらも鳩に餌をあげることもできたのだ
俺は彼がしマホだからって特別扱い節長崎
一緒にドライブにも入った俺は発問になってしまった雅紀が
いきたいと思ったところで
どこでも連れてってあげていたんだ
ブーブーなかったが4 f
でも
こんなことになるなんて思ってもいなかった
[音楽]
相談はぜひん
結局お前はさんの味が好きってことですね
バッハ
馬介
お前もこっちの生活も慣れただろううん
お腹減ったら充電すればそのし快適あっ
もう前へ思想スマホの中でもいいかもな馬鹿なこと言わないでよ
9月
[音楽]
不月
大臣か源さん来ちゃだめよねー
masaki
正ゲインっ
[音楽]
スマホの中でも
軍はに惹かれたら痛いんだよねバーガーこれ以上喋るなぁ
今中だよ
忠霊されないかくん
lightning ケーブルがやられている
小熊は砂糖前死んじまうよ大丈夫一さん
icloud にバックアップあったらん
それでお前は助かるのか
[音楽]
うすーだろう
通報として
源さんと過ごせた時間
楽しかった自分
[音楽]
この先
お酒ううっ
[音楽]
情け
私を知っ